readings from podcast Ville the church
or what's happening now is brought to
you by zip recruiter listen II know how
tough it is out there
to finally good employee you have any
idea if you're trying to run a business
whether it's small or large how tough it
is hiring is a challenge but there's one
place you can go where hiring is simple
fast and smart a place where growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates you're thinking they're going
Joe Joey where is this place that place
its zip recruit accom slash church all
right let me explain to you
zip recruiter sends you jumped over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job who
does that see it nobody and right now
the church family can try zip recruiter
for free that's right you heard it right
right now the church family could try
zip recruiter for free at zip recruited
com slash Church that zip recruiter calm
slash Church zip recruiter a smarter way
to hire this podcast is also brought to
you by Fuji Sports calm let me explain
something in the world the gi's match in
God's boxing glove what listen as far as
I'm concerned the martial arts Fuji
sports calm has been there since day one
they showed up but what's his name
Johnny Kimora when he she went to Brazil
Johnny come always wearing a Fuji sports
calm GE let me tell you some as far as
G's are concerned you know no bull smoke
up your ass guys if you're a big guy
eight three a four a five a six this is
the gay for you when they have you
enclosed guard they're trying to pawn
you pulling you're pulling you're
pulling you let me tell you something
they can tug for two hours I had a
better chance of killing themselves in
your collar then bringing you down or
ripping your [ __ ] quad that's the
quality of the ghee that's what I'm
trying to point out whether you have a
noogie [ __ ] suit the [ __ ] rash the
rash guards are tremendous or whether
you have a gig a m-- listen do me a
favor
how about the church what's happening
now go to Fuji Sports that come and
press in church back and get tempus
the Liberty house we kicked this [ __ ]
mule I love these [ __ ] things anyway
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
Uncle Joe we're here
my main man Brody Stevens and Lisa at
before we even start I want to thank you
guys that showed up to the taping of
Monday night listen man I felt like I
had rough sets I couldn't really get
into it and swing the bat fully but
that's my responsibility to be honest I
worked really hard I worked for a month
I wrote jokes I put jokes in and I
didn't get the result and I definitely
ultimately wanted I don't know how I
taped you know who the [ __ ] knows you're
up there you're thinking about something
else
but if you showed up and you support
thank you even if you didn't [ __ ]
support thank you very much cuz the
vibes were out Lisa at was there [ __ ]
cake quickly was there Theo van was
there Steve Simone was there D'Agostino
was there I mean it was just who he
spoke he was there it was [ __ ] badass
so thank you and I'm onething Netflix
for the opportunity and you know
sometimes you drop the ball you can't
always be a [ __ ] I'm a human I get
that you know what's up in your party
Stevens picking your [ __ ] fingers
whatever the [ __ ] yeah no I'm just I'm
listening I'm listening it's like you
know it's like a real reality doing
these uh you know these specials these
shows you don't know how it's gonna go
I've been lucky doing some of these
late-night shows I've been okay with I
have I do have a special coming out I'm
not like going right into a promotion
mode but I don't know how that's gonna
be taken I don't know I mean it's a
little different like I did well when I
did it okay but I don't know how it's
gonna cause it's a concept somewhat I
don't know how it's gonna play to the
masses so you know but they've been on
late-night television yeah I've done
three Craig Kilborn shows he was there
before The Late Late Show before Craig
Ferguson and James Corden I did Conan
maybe like five years ago for in the
middle of doing my Comedy Central show
so I I do it I mean I've you know gone
up and knocked out of the park in terms
of that like something about
live I can step up to Ivan done like a
you know Netflix taping I did the
warm-up for the Netflix back when they
they had a neighbor Godsey was on it and
fortune Teamster did the warm up for
that that was kind of cool but yeah you
don't know you just keep doing it I'm
staying positive I'm have him trust in
my instincts I feel like I'm not saying
my backs against the wall but I feel
like I've stepped up the plate on my
comedy stuff I'm not like you know my
acting I wish I was a better actor I get
nervous about that somewhat but stand-up
I've been able to I think I do OK in the
stand-up or doesn't just once I find my
groove acting you know that's more
that's harder for me you're very funny
and you uh have you you like the
midnight yeah that I went into the
office at the comedy stuff I turn around
there's a picture in a wall I couldn't
stop [ __ ] laughing on the drive home
I thought about how you're like Kennison
you're like going up at midnight so
build that build that market there's
people who really like watching comedy
at midnight yeah you can go into a town
into a rock club and do a [ __ ]
midnight show and you do fantastic
mm-hmm on a Friday night or Saturday
Saturday night better she could fly out
Saturday morning and be back Sunday
morning with no drama no radio you sell
what yourself a midnight showing a rock
club after a band you do for them yeah
that's the one spot I do you know I do
the Comedy Store that late-night spot
and I'm I'll be doing it tonight
actually and it's I'm relaxed because
there isn't that that pressure on me
like I can do audience warm-up in a
packed room thousands of people or
what-have-you but the late-night spot
for stand-up for me I'm very relaxed and
I can talk I get my jokes in but that's
the you know the comedy story you know
like in the original room you got to
bring it energy you know tight for the
most part and then that main room if
you're up there when it's packed and
you're in there you know yourself or Joe
Rogan or D'Elia you got to bring it so
that could be stressful for some people
possibly
would be for me if I don't do it enough
with that late-night spot it's just like
less pressure on me and I get to be mime
not trying to prove myself because
people don't always get me right out of
the gate and then I get like nervous I
go well you know this and I know some
people like it but it's it's stressful
for me like trying to impress people
where is that late-night spot I sit on
the stool
that's another that I'm sitting on the
stool recently like just kind of keeps
me grounded how many spots do you think
you guys have done so your career oh I
don't I would say I mean Joey probably
more but maybe the first two years I did
like five spots a month really six but
not even before yeah yeah because six
months if I got a job house MC so I gave
me four spots automatically on Tuesdays
mm-hmm every one so I reach out to do
something else that there was not
paternity so I can't say that I was lazy
I didn't really know what was going on
and then when I went back to Boulder 94
is when I really had bearings about me
so I figure from [ __ ] 94 to 97 I was
doing 25 spots a month that's all had 16
you know that average that's like 20 but
once I moved to Iowa my spots went up a
lot 97 I was doing 30 spots a month and
I did that steady to 2004 so there was
five years there for sure I was doing
360 spots just in those five years
so that's 1800 right there alone I mean
there's people who count they're set so
you know dean del rey probably know
exactly oh you do
yeah see I I haven't I don't know really
you uh you look at you in your notebook
you go this was seven well forgot how
much money I made that night how my set
went what did I try I've been doing that
since see how really I go my notebooks
go all the way back now to like ninety
eight ninety yeah I think this one in
the middle that we throw away by mistake
like 2007 or 2008 I throw away my
mistake but everything else
my wife has in boxes you'd be [ __ ]
surprised so will you go like on a
midweek set today like at the Comedy
Store
you know your oh are you'll mark that
down you'll look at your notes and
you'll sit and you'll go that's
especially the last couple of months
because you've been working on yeah [ __ ]
well like that was kind of what I was
trying to get to is you guys have done I
don't know five thousand ten thousand
spots I don't know I'm not I'm not gonna
I'm like I felt bad the way you felt
about your Netflix special because I'm
not saying you went in there and and had
a set that people will talk about for
centuries but it wasn't I've seen you
bomb I've seen I've seen I obviously I
liked in at like the like late night
haha or something where like there's
three people and they don't like you
because you teased and like I've seen
you have bad sets but that wasn't a bad
set it was like there were things that
didn't hit as hard as maybe you would
have liked and you can always say things
differently but I like I hope you're
proud of it I thought was a good you
know and I wish it were the gun you know
you can't have everything you can't
always get what you want but you get
what you need you know it's been sent a
thousand [ __ ] times I'm very
fortunate to even be in the game at this
age they even be around you know so they
think positive that happens I'm [ __ ]
happy yeah you know somebody calls and
says they like me till you have to put
me in the show I'm happy I'm 55 probably
I don't give a [ __ ] anymore you wanna
say mm-hmm I love doing comedy I love
but it's not like well that was 32 what
it meant to me at 32 it does mean the
same to me I still love it just failure
like if you don't like me at this age I
don't really give a [ __ ] yeah I'm saying
you know who I am but you want me to
come down and read for your role for a
gangster and he's 55 go [ __ ] yourself
I've been around as far as you have you
put me in two movies but I gotta come
downtown at 3:30 in traffic and drive
back in that [ __ ] nightmare give it
to somebody else
you want to be a hypocrite they gonna
call me okay okay we'll let you read to
mom holding it then they know I'd better
round like a book this I'm not just
coming at 3:00 cause you want a mus on
me right you know those days are done
with like all those type of situations
it that we've been here a long time
growing both of us is that because you
you're I guess older right is that what
you're saying you're feel older you know
what it's gonna work and what's not
gonna work anymore
you know you know when I was 38 I
couldn't wait to be on the show put me
on a show now and I can't I couldn't
handle it why because I just couldn't
handle with all the freedom we've had
the last couple years I wouldn't want to
be on some TV time commitment and you
know what they're gonna say creativity
can't say this can say this you can't do
this is it really worth it to recur on
the show right now the only show that
would be Walter to recur as if it was
your own show it was that way and you're
pulling down 50 G's a week cuz it's your
name and created by and by by movement
at the end of the week yeah you talk
Twitter go [ __ ] themselves and you know
you tell everybody go [ __ ] themselves
you'll see him in five years
and then you can curse he could say suck
my dick you could say racial slurs you
can say whatever you want but until that
time he's gotta stay off Twitter yeah
that's a tough thing to sort of put
pictures up with your kids playing
bongos and you you know think about what
your [ __ ] buddies at some barbecue why
have it if you really can't put Express
who the [ __ ] you are yeah and it's
stressful for you know every tweet you
put out there no I can get in trouble or
who's there gonna think about you know
that about mates if you're listen you're
a comic if you tweet something and you
tweet it and it's funny and it's in good
taste there's a thousand variables that
goes to that tweet but it's in good
taste
yeah nobody's ever gonna say that even
if it's a little off base well I'm
talking more of you know maybe something
current event news newsworthy that sort
of thing I'm not always some time not
always comical with those
and I feel like and then also I like to
make some points but I think there's
just backlash
you know if I'm like I'm from the valley
I'm blue-collar and so every tweet I put
out I just I don't like the problems
I get nervous being on Twitter
interacting well you know you call me
you're a phone call guy I like that you
know me but if I was to like hey Joey on
Twitter and I feel like everyone's
watching us so I kind of and I've had
experiences with people like you know
just over the years about getting it not
getting in trouble hey don't put me on
that don't you know I've tried to reach
out that people like get weirded so for
me I've kind of it's I hold back on it I
like talking I like periscope because I
don't think I don't think about it so
Twitter it's uh it could be it's a
stressful for many reasons I could see
why people are leaving it because of the
hate or they're you know you feel like
maybe you're wasting time or you are
gonna say something wrong so I I don't
need it but it's fun trying to have fun
with Twitter at least I try to show
positive that's a thing like I never
want to like brag either I'm aware of
like when I promote the Comedy Store I
know guys want to get spots so that
that's kind of you know I don't like I
know I need to promote the Comedy Store
and it's good to have people see Oh bro
- you're at The Comedy Store so I can
get work elsewhere also like go on the
road I don't do a lot of road work so
you know it's just social media I think
people are waking up and seeing the you
know like there's some negativity but I
again I try to show positive so what I
do I don't not trying to change mine so
I'm saying like look putting out
positive energy to get to be at the
Comedy Store positive energy get to do
uh positive vibes not being a hater and
I you know it I could be a hater I'm a
human right you know but try to take the
high road I think both of you have done
good jobs about Ahana not dictating your
audience but Brody you're like you you
do it different ways bar you do blocked
which I like you've reached we don't say
block tonight that's
see what I do now is I don't even really
either mute them if they're just like I
don't really want to do with that
anymore or if I don't look like I really
don't like what the saddest blonde I
don't go back and forth with them Joey
you get a bailout rare more rare now I
think at least from what I see but every
once in a while you'll go off on them
which i think is probably scare some
people from coming at you i as you've
had some interaction it's crazy because
it's not even me it's 200 savages oh
yeah that's the best that come after you
on Twitter and Facebook
my niece made it remark one day they
tortured it so she had to drop off
Facebook okay on Facebook years ago four
or five years ago when she was at Temple
she made a comment one night about
something comedy and I saw the demise
yeah I saw one Facebook [ __ ] message
another one you know another one and the
next we know she was she [ __ ]
believing me she deleted me as a friend
I mean yeah there I think there's a lot
of there's bullying I think that's one
thing that happens I feel and that's a
fear of mine having putting stuff out
there and having but that's you know
what you got to grow up if you're in
this business that's just a reality
right now in terms of you don't have to
be on social media but it's kind of hard
not to when they tell you you got to
promote this you got to get on gonna get
on there but I think you know everyone's
kind of like fatigued right now with
just this craziness so in I try to keep
it light and polite but it's not easy
you're very sweet listen I have a rough
to be there from time to time but I have
to tell you that I've taken a lot of
chances on Twitter and I've learned one
thing it it's like a background check
not the problem with a background check
is I really can't see what's it in your
mind or in your heart yeah a background
check is a piece of paper so right now I
come in here and you do a background
check out me mm-hmm
kidnapping comes up the aggravated
robbery the
you know whatever happened to Seattle in
possession of coke that my brother put
on their possession of weed you look at
me and you make a judgement and then you
talk to me and you make another judgment
you know that Nicholas Cruz kid let's
just use him he comes in he has a clean
bill of Rukn record but look at him it
don't take a genius to tell that kids
[ __ ] [ __ ] from day one yeah all
those people when they come in you could
tell they're [ __ ] but you're so
blinded by the sale you're so blinded by
the commission or whatever the structure
is of your payment that you oversee
those things you oversee those things as
an employee whose eyes are too close
together that the kids got PMS [ __ ]
pants you know there's a thousand tells
and you're missing all of them yeah you
could tell he's a half a [ __ ] Momo oh
you know I'm saying you can't tell this
kid was a half a mum or half of them
they come in for an ar-15 I'm gonna [ __ ]
their by it
look at that [ __ ] eyes they got a
glaze over their [ __ ] eyes they look
like they just got Frank you can see I
can hit them you can see you know that
something's going on and see that with a
background check you know you can see
that [ __ ] with a background check it's
so weird I look at the point this is the
lay back so you got a look at them in
the eye
you get a real true reader on somebody
as opposed to Twitter wall twit no no no
all I want you to understand from this
is that what I like about Twitter well I
really like about Twitter and all this
[ __ ] is say what's in your [ __ ] heart
listen now joke you're gonna write about
Trump or whatever stupidity you're gonna
write that's a really good joke you
can't put it on the special because by
the time you put on the special people
it's not going to be relevant so you
might as well put it somewhere like your
Embraer this week right yeah okay so BAM
you wake up what's up y'all positivity
is the word of the day y'all okay then
the second line is the line you just
created about some politician or
Roseanne or whatever the [ __ ] you want
to say then the third line is your dates
and breath guarantee you'll sell 10%
more tickets because you gave them a
[ __ ] joke first and you asked them
how they were in your positivity
if I see you know a couple months ago
you got in trouble didn't you something
happened and how they know is by your
tweets how people which one which one I
was so you had a situation where people
came to help you and how they knew were
people contacted a bunch of people and
said that these were regular brownie
tweets are you talking about a few years
ago yeah oh yeah yeah well yes of course
so thank God that people really love you
and they look at your Twitter feed and
the people who called around looking for
you knew your heart they knew what you
were saying was crazy but they knew your
heart so always a member if you say an
off-color jokes on Twitter people know
who Brody is people that know who Brody
is they're not gonna get offended it's
when they retweet that joke and some
[ __ ] look at the law reads that joke
and says look what Brody Stephens said
about people with their eyes closed -
yeah you know well I don't push it
in that sense I push it maybe in
political like I'm not out there like
Owen Benjamin was I'm not I don't think
where is old Benjamin what is the final
detail well he's off Twitter and I think
he's doing I he's doing time Instagram I
think I think you just went he brought
his family somewhere I saw that was the
last I sounded to him well we time you
go on Instagram that goes into a
satellite where you are so eventually
gonna find them to shoot them in [ __ ]
that movie is oh my god Instagram is fun
I keep it I just show my ID show photos
and again it's not bragging to but just
showing some fun stuff at some companies
feel a lot of people who brag on their
they show pictures of money oh yeah well
I that's a big thing that little rappers
do you know they walk around with like
stacks and they like throw it on the
floor but I think comedians showing them
on like a private air way we're taking a
private jet that I'm not into
necessarily all the time fans I didn't
drive it in fancy just kind of like not
that all comedians do that but
something you know just oh yeah that's
why I take my photos I'm by myself in
the restaurant everyone's happy and all
the time and I get it but what a minute
million dollars a year what would be
different by your life Brody right now I
think it'd be a little more relaxed
how would you would you live in bigger
digs would you drive a Porsche No
Porsche Carrera no would you have a
butler and the snow and a publicist and
somebody to tell you were great
I might having a somebody to help me
like Anna maybe an assistant to keep
things in line but no I don't need a
butler I would you know I'm okay with
the small condo oh I don't need huge
stuff I get to do cool things already
I'm already getting to do major league
baseball fantasy camp type activities
they get to go to the Comedy Store and
do whatever I want
I get to do podcasts so you know having
fun with that
so I all I need honestly is shelter
eventually I'd like to have a
relationship I like to have a dog I
wouldn't mind having a kid I just in I
just don't know if that's gonna happen
but if it if it doesn't I'm okay well
you love me 48 I just turned you're a
young man
you just think that seven six more years
a good dick yeah you know I look up to
you guys I look up to you I look up to
Dean Chang Forbes he's got Eddie
Pepitone these guys like who are you
know a little little bit older than me
like I look up to you guys it's like
okay they're doing it I can do it so I I
feel good about that and you know it's
like I think relationships matter and
again we're getting that Twitter stuff
again you're a lot of times you're by
yourself and but I'll say something it's
been so crazy the last couple years with
politics
I felt like honestly I had to put my
energy into that into put into like
sticking up for myself sticking up for
good people if you want to say I'm just
not crazy progressive I I really want
everybody want everybody to do well
everybody and I think that I go home I
go to the comedy store and I go home and
I go on that internet and I'm just
searching I'm just putting out that's
where my mind is I think I think I don't
think I'm alone in that like in terms of
it's hard doing to enjoy things I used
to enjoy things a little more but I
would say the last year or so I think
just with the the tension in the air I'm
not enjoying things is that how you feel
at all or what do you think I don't
follow politicians because there are
some times where I'll go check and I'll
just start going on like well goose
chases I'll click on this person's
Twitter and little good this person's
Instagram and yeah you can get
frustrated or angry if you don't believe
in what they're doing or yeah on
Instagram sometimes it's just like these
people are getting millions of followers
for doing like I'm saying some money on
the floor it's so they're either it can
get but I try to I try not to do that so
that's why people cuz people get mad at
me because I don't follow that many
people but I only like I literally
follow Who I am interested in hearing
from and but I I feel like I'm a
comedian my thing is I was born here
let's just say Hollywood and everyone
doesn't really like people are down on
Hollywood let's be honest whether that's
just a fact people are kind of down on
it and I feel as though I was born here
I'll say the valley Hollywood was born
in Hollywood and live in Hollywood I
work in Hollywood I specifically am in
comedy on the front lines of like First
Amendment speech and a lot of these
comedians are you know they're a Patton
Oswalt Judd Apatow you know Joe Rogan
he's more known for the podcasting but
even that so I feel like I need to speak
up I need to I can't like not say
anything I just feel like I have to
speak my mind because I'm from here born
here and I hear things that just kind of
like don't doesn't feel right to me and
I felt that you know and I've worked in
show business I've been in movies I've
been I've done 3,000 television audience
warm-ups I had you saw I had every high
school come in
every military branch and then when
things starting you know just I just
feel like I have to stick up for what's
right in what you could take it for
whatever it I don't get political but
that's what I do but I also feel like
enough be and I had my own personal
experiences so I don't want to go into
that but you know I'm not I have my
reasons for how I feel about things so
I'm not trying to change people's
opinions but I want to let them know you
like today that I hang out with the Cubs
that's pretty cool right why put out
good energy so why don't you listen to
me that's kind of how I feel sometimes
but yeah I'm sticking up for the valley
you know they used to pick on the valley
all the time Reseda sucks you're from
Reseda I went to Reseda
what that what the hell you know so and
I I got I got picked on but you know
what it made me stronger I'm just like
just admit it you know I had Latino guys
do Holocaust jokes black guys do jokes I
played sports the football team I code
those write the names though no but it
made but I but here's a deal but you're
talking about the background check these
guys weren't malicious I knew them like
I can name my Mexican teammate friends
and they would do Holocaust jokes and
Jude and Jew jokes it didn't it didn't
feel good but I knew it wasn't coming
from malicious right I could tell and
same thing when I played baseball in
college did the white guys from Orange
County in Arizona doing Jewish jokes I
get it so I just would say like Jesus is
Jewish and then they would laugh it
would like diffuse them into this day
I'm very good friends with those guys so
that's like looking them in the eye and
I just feel like there was just more
honesty back then and that that's just
how I was raised so I and I I'm kind of
I don't want to like make waves or
anything but I also feel like enough
people are you know quote unquote woke
and feel like I can back off and I want
to get back into just having fun rock
and roll music baseball enjoying things
I don't want to be involved in this
crazy you know political
Bunker feel like a [ __ ] out of there
yeah Wow it's that horrible bunker
yeah it's a help it's a you know you put
on world news tonight it's an
intelligent American you kind of put on
World News Tonight whatever
yeah first for 12 minutes is [ __ ]
presidential and stupid box yeah
so you mean Friday night will I take
mentally out but I spent [ __ ]
hard-earned money for tickets
the first recombinant look there and
bring that [ __ ] Harley back I see in
my liberal rule 13 hours a week I gonna
to escape this [ __ ] and go ahead a cat
some type of relation with the comic yep
ollie there's one comic to go up then
click with my inner [ __ ] ghost and
we're good to go
I got one guy that related with the 13
minutes that's saying exactly what I
feel Wow he took that right out of my
[ __ ] mind that's what great comedy is
and then somebody says a woman goes up
dead says what your wife's thinking or
your girlfriend like girl on the first
day you look like a [ __ ] hero you
look like a [ __ ] hero you know until
you go back the next night to watch the
same comic and he sucks dick yeah are
you like what the [ __ ] I kind of got my
dick sucked last night but I went for
the double whammy now I'm not gonna suck
my dick my cousin staying over what a
coincidence the comedian bombs the
cousin stay no what you lose ain't bad
for everybody
yeah no it's uh pretty interesting [ __ ]
no but I'm happy that probably just a
fact that you still here I stole mine
was having a conversation by Eagle in
New York yeah in 97 you told me to so
for you just to still be here
do you know how hard it is that this is
what listen I get it I didn't do the
performance I'd water too but there's a
lot of variables involved in this and
I'm a big boy I've been doing comedy for
27 years on the flip side of that the
flip side of that is I got an F like
special whatever happens now I was in
God's hands there's nothing I could do
I'm very happy we hit some good spots we
hit some great jokes
it just wasn't caught up the way I
wanted to in my head and it happened
but guess what guess how lucky I am to
still be in the game yes how lucky I am
I came to Los Angeles but I went full
[ __ ] throughout and went for it
guess [ __ ] that that means the world
to me because this comics
like [ __ ] came up with their way
funny and I have more discipline
and at one point just couldn't make the
cut to move to Los Angeles that was
their biggest obstacle was taking their
[ __ ] it was getting out of their
[ __ ] [ __ ] situation they wanted
to be a big man on a small campus I
didn't give a [ __ ] about being a small
fish in a big ocean I knew that I would
get to the island and then grow and get
some utensils get a flashlight and
eventually we built a whole [ __ ] stage
and that was exactly what happened you
know that's exactly what happened we
clung on to a rock we plant on a [ __ ]
scene on that rock and after a few years
we built the stage we all like the
license you know that's that's the thing
that's it
we played there was hurdles in front of
us you know your um
Mele was asking about spots and all that
and Seattle for me I learned to public
speak up there selling t-shirts for the
Seattle SuperSonics then doing the cable
access show and then when I went to New
York I was a tour guide at Radio City
Music Hall I barked at the Comedy Cellar
so I always tried to make sure that I
had jobs where I was able to project and
talk and I feel like that helped me out
quite a bit like I would always say find
a job where you can talk learn you know
speaking so for me it was like selling
those t-shirts you could just gotta step
up and go for it
same thing we're like audience warmup
you just gotta like go for it you can't
be and that's you know some of these
people lay on these small markets or
they're they're afraid to like go for it
and that that's what you know I learned
Seattle was good for that for me I I
found my voice in Seattle I honed it in
New York and then I came back here and
and got into warm-up and all that stuff
but yeah you told me back in 97 go to
New York and I went to New York and I
never looked back from Seattle was like
boom and I was that's where be you know
I came out in terms of myself
how did he decide to go to Seattle cuz I
know you started here briefly right yeah
you know I played baseball basically all
the way through college and I coached at
Arizona State so at the final semester
and I took an acting class at Arizona
State and it was kind of cool like I was
finally away from baseball and it was
just a nice not that I didn't like
baseball but I was kind of like over it
and then I took this acting class at
Arizona State
there's cute girls in there and there
were you know cute girls in there and
was fun and I was trying to be a serious
actor but they would a guy like Joey
farting in the back of your class no we
had some characters in there I remember
but I mean yeah be the girl the people
would laugh at me so then so I took the
acting and when I moved back here to Los
Angeles I worked on a student film I
just wanted to learn everything about
the business we're having a good laugh
here I'm trying to like not smell the
fart but also speak into the mic it's
everything can we I don't want to
interrupt you but since he's since he's
bringing it up can we talk about that
when you assaulted me during the
periscope that was I still can't believe
he did them Joey
assaulting you by farted and called me
over for to a do a technical thing I
just left me there waiting for it to
shorten and totally 30 seconds to show
up and he cupped it
oh he cupped it and threw it and it was
shocking thank you I appreciate it but
that's the kind of relationship you two
have when you can fart on each other
oh well but that's real brotherly
interaction to be able to fart and the
way to sit there and flaws they kept
saying where is it where is it I'm like
tell me no smell this bomb of death oh
it was only a travel sick
I mean you know just six inches from my
ass oh is that close
I had it pointed right up at you know
it's like a [ __ ] like a magnet you
know I don't [ __ ] know til this day
it happens so fast you know
hello for you have any [ __ ] idea how
fast it happened okay like if you look
at your calendar on your phone yeah it
was Memorial Day May 31st right so I met
that broad of a Sunday night at the
comedy club and she spent the night and
one day day I gave her a ride to her
house we fooled around we got through a
house a little bit and then I drove all
the way to Colorado this was Monday
mm-hmm by the following Monday she was
already in Colorado on my couch we hung
out we she drove me do calmly we went
camping together she left to follow on
Monday before she left I booked I
trouble run and I was I was in Seattle
maybe ten days after I met took me ten I
knew I knew way before well I went to
Denver when I went to Michigan that week
and I know handle Ebola I know it ever
all the pieces came into play and I'm a
miss still driving pastured where the
devil's play the red the Red Wings to
Detroit Red Wings Joe Louis Arena I
stood on the driving past that arena
crying because the realization had sunk
in it they that was on the [ __ ] go to
jail for murder
well I was gonna have to leave Boulder I
either I was gonna commit to comedy and
just stay on the road
like I remember driving and going this
is what I want to do if I could figure
out a way to do this every night even if
it's for 25 bucks until like a [ __ ]
$10,000 falls out of this
guy I'll be fine if I can keep this car
together and I could just do calmly
every night 25 bucks middle
I'll Drive every [ __ ] night it
doesn't matter me I got a [ __ ]
four-cylinder car it's 56 miles to the
[ __ ] gallon gallons a dollar 50 or
[ __ ] you know a [ __ ] gallon I
could you know I could go anything with
your miles in this [ __ ] car so it
that's what I wanted to do but that's
how bad I [ __ ] was I stole my--my
driving by that [ __ ] Stadium crying
though and I have to leave Boulder
doesn't not I'm not gonna see this kid
I'm not gonna end up in jail but I got
up there in the first night it was like
remember what I told you leaving and
calmly you get these little [ __ ]
kicks and the answers hey I made a few
liverwurst sandwiches or American cheese
on white and I made a couple bologna
sandwiches and I wrapped them up like a
six-pack of sodas and chips and bagels
and cream cheese
hmm but I drove all night and that's all
I hate I would get out of the car to pee
but I would bring my own food on house
trip morons and I still remember a
[ __ ] plank get into the Troy and
being out of food and just having an
ashtray filled with change and maybe
four joints and [ __ ] going wow that
was an epiphany of me wanting to do
family that's it that's my calling this
is what I'm gonna do
this was not that bad this dirty hour
drive without a hotel and without shower
wasn't that bad it didn't kill him in
fact it was fun I listen to music I
smoked dope I ain't good you drove from
Denver to Detroit or Detroit for a gift
for four hundred and fifty dollars for
one two three one two three four five
six seven shows is that gig still
available no oh no that club isn't even
there
No so you drove to Detroit and it was a
Tribble
that was a triple no right was a regular
run that a friend of mine hooked me up
but it was a comedy club and one of the
suburbs of Detroit dear boy yeah and I
get there so here I am ready to [ __ ]
pursue calmly this is my dream I [ __ ]
got here
I hate the bagels I hate the cream
cheese I ain't the [ __ ] sandwiches
I had the sodas I had the chips you know
I [ __ ] made it here I go to the club
and they're like there's no comedy
tonight I know what are you talking with
there's no comedy tonight it's closed
for a private showing okay as I shut up
to the pizza place because they the guy
that Atlantic Street pizza I don't know
what it in Seattle no no this is what
still talking Detroit back to Detroit
Dearborn Detroit got it sorry I jumped
to Seattle I go up to the corner and I
see the guy that booked the gig and he
goes dog you hear and night earlier Oh
Here I am thinking so I go what do I do
and he goes you got a car yeah looks
like you sleep welcome to come tomorrow
at 3 o'clock check-in at whatever we'll
have a hotel they'll be ready for you
tomorrow at 3:00 so I go where's the
hotel at how far from the club is just
right around the corner
so I asked somebody where the hotel was
my shadow with into a parking lot and
I'm at the parking lot maybe one hour
I'm walking around the hotel I'm
mingling with people you know I'm
talking with people at the bar like a
you staying here no I'm staying close by
but my friend is washing I made up some
[ __ ] [ __ ] story
and my big pager goes off and I said do
it from the pizza place and I call over
like what's up he goes do you have a
suit I go yeah and he goes go to the
hotel and check in he goes you got a
room at Tony Bennett's open I couldn't
come with him tonight so you're opening
up for Tony Bennett whoa he does I'll
give you 50 bucks and dinner so I pull
his suit on and checked into a hotel
room
but you believe me on a suit with you I
had everything in there that was the car
of death that car was gonna take me to
the end I had everything the car
couldn't even break down I had
everything for the car at that point I
had done five months a trip once I had
broken down 80 times I know exactly what
I needed what I didn't need and a
football a frisbee I had everything in
there there was no boredom in there
whatsoever shovels the ski never changed
for a car an extra battery radiating a
fixture that plugs up to radiate iPhone
charger no there's no phones in those
things nothing so you opening up for
Tony Bennett okay
let me open up for Tony Bennett I go to
one show I eat spaghetti and I go back
with to go to this beautiful [ __ ]
room and like I said I have a jar filled
with money like a box filled with money
an ashtray filled with change and the
next boy I get up and breakfast was free
they gave me I could coupon for
breakfast for free like screen those
days you eat anything and then some
scrambled eggs you don't even beep
scrambled eggs to petrify the English
toast the [ __ ] turkey bacon I mean
you just it's it's amazing but when you
were doing those triple runs did you at
did you was that where you want to do
comedy what was in Detroit I mean you're
already doing the triple runs no I was
doing comedy in the triple runs I was
doing Wyoming Oh God Wyoming was the
main one Idaho you know when that Chi
whatever the [ __ ] when you got to
Detroit that was the Epiphany that was
the that Drive let me know that this is
what I wanted to do gotcha it was pretty
cool that drive because not only did I
do
Joey's but I also shadow over and did
the black club downtown
just for jokes aside and just for
something they had two clubs one in
Chicago and one in Detroit
I went over led into the showcase of his
70s night it was just a great weekend I
have my four other clubs so I tried the
Joey's like midnight I went somewhere on
Saturday showcase there
and they gave me like 50 bucks and then
Sunday like I went back to the thing and
that's when I met Carol and you know we
got some coke as [ __ ] it was just a
great weekend as a feature act like I
didn't know it was this much fun on the
road I'm like okay so I really want to
do this and it's this much [ __ ] fun
in this this was after the triple runs
no yeah the triple runs season me I did
about five months I started with triple
January of 95 this was May of 95 mm-hmm
and I had already done like a ton of
triple runs plus I was stopping at clubs
and showcase it so whenever I was in the
club whenever I was in the area I would
showcase in the club I would force
myself to do that and that's how I
learned I pick up the phone and call
people and muscle and [ __ ] Glen learn
how to tell people listen is this lease
I got yesterday he'll be at the club
Sunday night no my assistant
uh my assistant [ __ ] broad he's gonna
be there let me answer when I go down
and kill the room he's probably gonna
being able to give me weeks right there
on location like I would say [ __ ] like
that manages a week those days you had
asked for a week why [ __ ] alright let me
check the calendar hold on um no no no I
would say to them when I go down and
blow up your [ __ ] room is your
assistant probably gonna be able to give
me a date or do I have to come and see
you because if I have to see you let me
come back and wonder when you're there
one day that's how boys ain't happy
getting burnt for a year on the road
well you start saying that [ __ ] to
people and they don't give a [ __ ] if
they're real they'll go come on now if
they're pieces of [ __ ] they'll go [ __ ]
you or nobody has ever spoken to me like
that before not since you know they'll
say Jerry sorry felt like that to make
themselves look good
do you bomb after saying someone like
that doesn't but does that you think
that kind of stuff goes on still like on
a tribal run that you know those kind of
things are going these you know dealing
with club owners like that sort of
or is it different now you know starting
up you take a lot of this [ __ ] it's like
any other anything else you come into
footlocker as a trainee you take you up
to clean the bathrooms you gotta you
gotta do a lot of stuff but you get the
referee shirt but eventually you get so
good at what you do with it you get
stuck giving other people [ __ ]
yeah general law of the land so it
comedy's just to saying you know when
you move to Seattle to New York there
was a couple Booker's you want to
totally go [ __ ] themselves and then when
you move from New York to LA you're like
wait a second now I got a handful of
[ __ ] I'm gonna call and tell
them to suck my dick like people didn't
want to use you if there's a handful of
people in your career that said you know
Brody you know have my style of comic
and now you want to call him after your
regular at the store at 10:30 every
night you're like hey [ __ ] you weren't
so smart after all [ __ ] you in your club
I'm a regular at the store and they're
like go [ __ ] yourself nobody right and
you know what that has happened to me
things like that that's what I got into
trouble with on Twitter I kind of lashed
out that and I was saying to guys like f
you for not being nice to me and you
know you so-and-so you were jerking when
it really bothers you it really bothers
you to see people before and after well
I just remember people not being cool
yeah exactly it's like I was in Seattle
Joey liked me
everyone like seemed to like me in
Seattle then I go to New York and law of
a sudden these guys don't like me it's
like debts and I understand like that's
human nature takes a while but you can
also see some people's true colors a
little bit early on if they're like not
cool to you so there was some of that
going on but also you know it's human
nature and I for me lashing out yeah I
might have been right at the core but it
wasn't the right thing to do and part of
that was that yeah I goofed up that's
where I was like on my those meds and I
went off from cold turkey and I had yeah
that's where I had my quote-unquote
problems and but I think it was just
like lashing
now I was a little I was a bit manic I
was worked up but they're also like
pushing me you know you're gonna push me
I'm gonna push you and I think some of
it was that a little bit like the
Hollywood the little bit of the
skateboarders from Venice those guys you
know rubbing up against me and I push
back so that's not always healthy but
that's what I did and you know but a lot
of people say oh Brodie you had a
breakdown I go no I went off my meds and
then I really opened up my mind and I
mean that's why they put people on meds
so you don't get agitated at things you
should be getting agitated with but I
was uh I was looking for problems a
little bit to going to Starbucks and
seeing these screenwriters giving me
negative energy I didn't like that so I
was like tapping into like real stuff
like people do talk about how there's
these how are these writers hang out at
Starbucks and how there's like these I
mean I got an argument at Starbucks a
couple weeks ago so you get these little
nerdy type guys and I can have problems
sometimes what do they say there well
one guy this most recent one I mean it
happens every few years but I was uh you
know how Starbucks is now I was all in
the news about the bathrooms and you can
hang out and do all that sort of stuff
so I walked into Starbucks my regular
Starbucks there in the valley and there
was a guy at the table a transient type
guy cuz I hadn't seen him before but I
could tell like he was a transient
energy yeah anybody was all we were like
at a table like we're on now and he was
all spread out
he had his backpack he had three
Chargers going he did have a coffee but
he was very spread out not a big deal I
thought it was kind of funny and I took
a photo and just on my own I think I
maybe I'll put that up but not showing
his who he is but just showing oh look
you people met people making their home
at Starbucks if I was gonna even do that
and then I walk closer as I go get my
coffee and I see the guy has a weapon
out there a bat-like
mini-bat with the tape on it like I know
it was a weapon sorry
and the weapon was on the table so not
only was the backpack and he was spread
out still funny now I see the weapon so
just kind of like to me it just verified
my initial instinct so I go you know
what I'll take a photo of the weapon why
not maybe I'll post that so I click a
couple shots of the weapon and I go get
my car you know on sly don't want to
make a big deal and then to take a clip
clip of the the weapon and then this guy
comes up to me goes hey yo what do you
what are you taking photos of like
friendly and I go I can see like I read
his energy like he was questioning me i
go and i zoom in my camera I go this
weapon and I go why he goes oh I thought
you were taking pictures of me and my
girlfriend I go why would I want to take
pictures of you your girlfriend goes I
don't know I go watch you get the [ __ ]
out of my face I'm about to knock you
out it was really I go yeah move and I
was getting worked up because this guy
freaking said I was taking pictures and
his wife and I go I told him I go I
didn't I said do I go and he's going
yeah you don't want to do that I go you
know what get I'm about to drill you he
said drill I don't know you know but I
was getting a little worked up and I go
nobody wants to take pictures of you and
your ugly wife that's what I said or
girlfriend so anything you got all
worked up and then the staff go break it
up guys break it up what what's going on
everything was cool he goes yeah I go
I'm taking a photo of the weapon and
then he goes yeah this sixty year old
guy so he called me a 60 year old guy
okay fine I go get my my coffee I'm
gonna leave kind of a still he's at the
table couple people around he's like
mumbling I go you got a problem you keep
talking I walk over they go nobody want
what I go nobody wants to take a picture
of you and you're ugly
I said no you're fat girlfriend that's
what I said
I called and I even oh [ __ ] I didn't
look at her I didn't even notice
I just know like if you're gonna say
that that's that's going overboard I
shouldn't have said it but I didn't
handle myself properly but the bottom
line is I wasn't taking pictures of him
and his girlfriend I don't even notice I
when he first came up to me I thought
was a fan or friend then he says yeah
you're taking a thought you're taking
photos with me and my girlfriend why
would I do that
well I don't know who you know get out
of my face
so I was I was upset and I got a little
worked up and I probably shouldn't have
said his girlfriend was ugly but I
that's just instinct sorry I'll go rogue
and but a bottom line is I took the
photo I probably shouldn't have that's a
risk so I took the risk I did ovary I
did was a bit sensitive about it I admit
that but you know what he could have
easily have gone to the manager and
that's a risk you take when you step to
somebody maybe they'll snap like me so
think twice and he was a little skinny
and Tifa type guy little weasel guy
that's what he was so I I just I pulled
him out of the woodwork I shook I shook
him up his cage got rattled definitely
you're gonna accuse me of taking photos
of you and your girlfriend like I'm a
creep I'm a peeping tom get the F out of
my face I'm taking a photo of the weapon
I haven't been back to that store bucks
I haven't went the weapon didn't I don't
know the guy the nothing who knows I
didn't care about the weapon I thought
it was funny I mean with Starbucks being
in the news I wasn't mad about the
weapon but I did take a photo of the
weapon because I thought it was funny
it's based off my instincts being right
but that's the risk you take but I
didn't appreciate it that I thought I
took a photo I mean if he was a big guy
probably would have got my ass kicked I
beep a lot of people and I worry about
that sometimes like I'm gonna be one
that somebody and and still not gonna
turn out well for me but I don't know
you beep at random people on the highway
the funniest thing in the world because
the beep comes from this in place I'll
tap whatever you gotta do if it comes
from Lunas in place a place with a hard
pay no you know when you pull up there's
something go ahead you [ __ ] jerk-off
move your car when you pull over and
beep or something and wave at them and
they feel really bad when you do
something like that it's a background
check
yeah let me do some fun things here
Jonathan Mary
love you J bish thank you Paul Lynch
Bablu Lingus Jeremy slay god daum DeNiro
Carson Williams Ivan Ramos and Pete the
Menace I love you [ __ ] always
thank you for all the well wishes for
the Netflix shooting you guys broke my
heart on Monday and Tuesday thank you
very much
who's the casino sold-out July 12th and
13th at the South Pointe and I have no
idea what's going on there check the
[ __ ] link and Utah wiseguys July 25th
and 26th check out the link and that's
it and that's that and I'm saying Brody
Stevens what else is cracking talk today
you're still getting your spots at the
store how many nights a week I get I
would say average to 2 to 3 a week they
love you damn it you know I'm ok with
that give me if I could not give me but
where else do you go up you go up Laugh
Factory improv when I call on for spots
I can definitely like show my face more
at shows and you know that that's up to
me so I feel like oh I'm not getting
enough spots or you know I could always
go do these you know backyard shows I
could go to the haha I can go places so
again I never I never blame others oh
it's always on me I feel like it's up to
me yeah there's the I just feel like and
that's probably my problem sometimes and
too hard on myself but well it's gonna
be hard you ever talk to a comic that
doesn't take responsibility for anything
you've been talk to a comic that
constantly kills you ever talk to a
comic that has the world by the balls
and [ __ ] at you because he has the
world by the balls or there goes guys
like that oh my god oh my can my
supposed to name one no they can't wait
to tell you about their success and how
you know this guy want them for a film
and deal but at the same time they tell
me how scared they are of making them
next [ __ ] move it's kind of weird if
you ever talk to something you feel that
they're scared of what's next sure you
know and it's like I was scared too for
a while we've all been scared when you
hear I mean that's part of the package
is fear the fears which dries your
every day when you wake up [ __ ] what's
gonna happen to it you know I have this
audition you prepare it and you don't
see an acting culture your last 48 hours
and you get to the room that everybody
you've watched on TV the last five years
so the [ __ ] energy gets sucked out of
your [ __ ] lungs but then you go into
a room and you know what you're going
there you think you close your eyes and
you see yourself at the store at 12:15
following one of the good ones
mm-hmm and you like [ __ ] what these guys
didn't do out there yeah they probably
have movies and they probably did this
and this but they could never follow
[ __ ] oh I'm following five nights a
week yeah it's kind of gives you like a
weird confidence you know stand-ups a
king of the jungle in terms of you know
so many people wish they could do
stand-up we're so lucky that we're
especially it we'll get to perform at
The Comedy Store and a lot of these
actors they can't do it and yeah I'm
lucky it feels good to be able to walk
in and comedians have been very nice to
me so I definitely feel feel support I
like you know you know they're they're
tough critics they're tough critics the
comedian's and they like you that's an
indicator of something you don't
necessarily want to be a comedian's
comedian I'll take it I'm not fighting
it but yeah it does feel good you know I
don't even know what standing up for now
I officially started going for it and
when I moved to Seattle February of 94 I
took Mitzi sandy seashores
comedy workshop it was always like a
comedy store guy I wanted to go to the
comedy store it was a kid I would see it
and I just felt like that's where I was
going how far away from the store did
you grew up as a kid well I grew up in
the valley but my mother her boyfriend
Jack he lived right there in Alta Loma
and off his patio you can see the comedy
store so as a kid I would always see the
energy I could feel it and I wasn't
necessarily you know wanted to do
stand-up but I was just I was around it
I was around that I saw that as a kid I
saw the Comedy Store and then when I was
took the work
back in 93 over at UCLA the Comedy Store
workshop after every class I'd drive to
the Comedy Store and I'd look at it and
go one day maybe I'll get to the door
who is that when you used to go look at
it
well that was bad whoever was performing
back in 90 yeah 93 but I wouldn't go in
I don't I don't think I ever went in
because it just didn't feel like I was
morally I wouldn't think another than 93
I think no it'd been scared shitless
[ __ ] you yeah I mean I was scared even
once I once I got past it was kind of
intimidating timid ating there at the
Comedy Store you know some real like
real men there you know tough guys chewy
in the parking lot you had it was just
very it was a dark place but I liked it
I always always liked the you know the
no frills of the Comedy Store wasn't
about advertising and fancy lights it
was dark it was real and I knew early on
like Mitzi accepted characters real
people who had problems you know so I
knew that right away and I was just
drawn to that and when I had an
opportunity to do a workshop and a lot
of people go why do you do a workshop
you should just jump into open mics
I need a structure I need playing
baseball Arizona State I needed
someplace to go and every Wednesday I
would drive to Westwood from Tarzana and
I was really excited to go do my little
two-minute spot in front of my
classmates so that was a big check for
me okay I like this so I'd go do it and
like I talked Sandy's ear off after the
show just I wanted to really just soak
it all in and then I'd go by the store
and then I did like one open mic and I
knew I wasn't I did a graduating class
at The Comedy Store crushed in the
original room 1993 packed people coming
up to me you have an agent this and that
I felt like a comedian and then like two
days later I go to my first open mic out
in Chatsworth and it was just like out
in the valley it was just like not good
but I I understood I go I get it I just
don't want to go this route especially
in my hometown
something something like a pride to feel
like I'm not gonna let this emcee at a
bar kind of like talk down to me in my
neighborhood you moved here from
somewhere I'm sure and this is my town
so I knew that and I stopped with the
open mics and I went back to UCLA and I
took a business of comedy class I wanted
to learn everything about comedy and I
did that and then I remember they could
the guy the instructor said if you want
to do comedy get out of LA go somewhere
else so it was either Phoenix or I went
to college or Seattle where I had family
and Seattle my uncle said they really
support the Arts up there so when I
moved up there in February of 94 after
this Northridge earthquake I was working
at Macy's over on Topanga and the mall
got red tagged so I didn't have a job
there and wasn't making much money
anyway and then I just drove up to
Seattle jumped into the comedy
underground open mics and just you know
the comedian's treated me pretty well I
was I was liked there but I made it to
the pie found my voice but that was
about it I wasn't gonna really get
feature work you know it's like they
knew me too well so I was a guest spot
guy and I worked at the comedy
underground I learned how to seat the
audience I learned about a three-person
show I learned all about that stuff and
doing the cable-access working for the
Sonics and then you said go to New York
and I knew it because I needed more CI
grout grew Seattle it's hard to like we
you they know you too well where I
started I went to New York and I just
enjoyed my time there but after three
years I felt like I was ready to come
back home and then I've been pushing
ever since like eighteen years of
pushing and pushing and yeah I don't
know where my next gig is gonna come
from but I do know that I have my
special coming out I do know that I mean
I am getting it two to three spots I
mean those two get taken away at The
Comedy Store who knows but I don't want
to think about that but I'm definitely
like I I do feel good about my comedy
feel like I've done a pretty good job
with that have I bought a house no but I
probably could have been better with my
probably made enough money to where it
could own a home but I think I honest
and I've talked about this before I
think if my father was still around but
maybe my comedy would be different if I
had a girlfriend if I had somebody to
kind of like keep me honest you know
keep me you know being a bachelor is
difficult you know the older you get and
especially you're in comedy and this and
that sort of thing so it makes you look
at things a little bit differently you
know you can get and you can I can see
why people get older they get a little
panicky keep going gonna get some fresh
air well do you remember you guys are
talking about the comedy storm Brody
you're a big fan of baseball so as a
comedy fan the stores pretty much like
family park and what whatever one look
like Yankee Yankee Stadium whatever and
I had the joy was very nice and put me
on his belly room show mm-hmm and it's
just I've been I've done a few maybe I
don't know 10 15 stages at this point
yeah but just having like there's a
difference with the crowds there and it
was just it was like a crazy like mine
my legs almost were shaking it's it's
pretty intense just even though I was in
the belly room which is the smallest of
the three but uh-huh
it was still like I don't want to say
the word religious but it was just it
was a very emotional experience your
adrenaline gets going you realize where
you are I don't want to run the light so
I think I did like 10 seconds a person
that's every 90 days when you go into a
a club that you read about I heard about
you know your legs go out for month yeah
I was watching me and but I was watching
everybody that night it was so electric
in that room that you could bomb and
they were still gonna laugh like I could
bring a dead guy in the [ __ ] back in
the room in the sonic electricity in the
room yeah woulda helped the shoulders up
like the [ __ ] Tin Man it was amazing
let me ask you this how important for
the younger comics for people like Lee
how important was the underground fear
from 95 to 97 98 to you I very important
doing those open mics getting you know
signing up for the open mics driving you
know to the comedy underground going to
the number one teriyaki next door and
then you know being around Josh wolf
yourself
Tayna Yoshi Ramona and then having all
these you know pretty successful
comedians who worked the cruise ships up
in Seattle and then I just enjoy me
personally I really enjoyed my time up
in Seattle because I was in that I was
in Phoenix I was in the desert I was so
third I need had a thirst for culture
thirst for Pierce earrings and capital I
needed that flavor and culture so
Seattle gave me that and then just the
comedy underground
doing the open mic every Monday and
Tuesday and Carl you know running the
open mics and all the characters there
and being in Pioneer Square was kind of
cool I enjoyed you know the baseball the
Mariners are playing at the Kingdome
they get maybe 3,000 a game the players
like the Oakland A's and the Indians and
the Yankees they'll be hanging out
upstairs so I really do you know I meant
of course we all miss our time there's
it was cool but I'm you know I'm
probably I enjoy my time at the Comedy
Store also enjoyed my times in New York
but the definitely Seattle was was good
for me and being being a part of the
desana selling the t-shirts it was a
breeding ground if you really think
about it look at you leave three guys
including yourself I still in the
[ __ ] get it yeah and they're making
noise down here
that was a breeding ground at that time
we didn't know it we had no idea for me
it was cow because like when I go to the
my friend Donovan who was on the podcast
two weeks ago donovan patton has been
going over to the fifth fourth wall and
his wife told my wife that she knows you
know I've been with Donovan for a while
and he really enjoys going over there
he says it's very supportive when you
get into economy like when I started I
started Denver Comedy Works I was doing
good with some people with some people
you know how some colonies are well you
just can't do nothing to win them over
you know and you're looking for this
home will be looking for this home but
then I get thrown out of that and I
ended up at Seattle and after a month it
was home right now I watch it with you
that I see how important that is for you
over there
are you going up up there like I always
say you go up and you want to go up
without a safety net well over there
you're going up with a safety that they
like you they like you're not gonna get
booed I got like a bottle thrown at your
head they cheer feet with your friends
all you guys cheer for one another I see
that that's a great environment to grow
it you know it's when I'm doing well and
Brody's doing well Brody's got a camp
and I got a camp and now every time we
go in there we try to outdo each other
but Rob wallet has his hand and you know
Sal whatever has his camp so it's just
that's horrible and I try to I bump him
and he like the comedy store before this
[ __ ] well there was any grift friend and
dice and mouldy and you know it was a
great experience but you look at it
compared to now and now it's like there
ain't no bump it you want to call it
four spots you call them four spots will
let you come in one time tonight and
bump but once you get that light it's 10
[ __ ] minutes and we'll shut the
microphone off you understand me you
like
yeah like the word got out what why do
you think that is the case now people
are more accountable for each other due
to social media that sort of thing or no
the Comedy Store was mitzi created a
haven for people to grow mm-hmm but she
also created a haven for people to hate
oh really she created this little haven
where she kind of inspired that in a way
I don't know how they saved she inspired
at all she thought it was necessary for
the growth of a comic which it really is
it really is it really is hard when they
when you and me sit there every night
smoke dope and do coke and drink and
we're pissed about Lee's success you
know what man I still remember give him
Lee jobs he's not [ __ ] funny [ __ ]
that [ __ ] for that little Jew
[ __ ] and then one night you catch
yourself you go look at me how am I
supposed to grow what I made of my
friends you know many [ __ ] people
would pull me aside and give me an e a
beatin about Josh wolf when he first got
his deal and for the first month or so I
joined in a few times I'm not gonna lie
to you but after that I was like
whenever always say this guy is not
friend regardless so what I think it's
not really what I think or what [ __ ]
he thinks it's what they think that's
number one number two we don't have time
to think about Josh wolf because we're
too busy thinking about ourselves why do
I give a [ __ ] what lisa ann is doing all
he ain't going that's an you know when
you're going to an open mic going to an
open mic is like working on a TV show
and watching extras the extras are
always either stockbrokers and they can
make you a million dollars or they good
friends with James Cameron they don't
have a [ __ ] story but meanwhile
they're an extra and you sit there and
take that story and yo oh my god really
meanwhile he's looking at that time
clock the one I wish there's all the
time I wish this happen time but he's
telling you he's a millionaire
he owns a yacht in San Diego and I was
watching the guy the other day be an
extra and then between takes he was
trying to work this girl tell her she
can make a ton of money and I'm sitting
oh look at this [ __ ] Barracuda this
guy it never stops this is the [ __ ]
homebred for sexual harassment
this was sexual harassment was invented
nice black girl with a big ass tight
skirt hmm and this white guy is trying
to sell her [ __ ] goats in [ __ ]
Arizona and some [ __ ] I said I go when
does it [ __ ] end with these guys but
no it's been great for your journey and
now now this special you tape this is
the one that was going to see so yes and
then they pulled it well see so went
away see so went away and my agent
manager they bought or sold reached out
and now it's gonna be on Amazon on June
22nd I believe is that is our date and
you can pre-order it and it's uh I I
shot it at The Comedy Store I think I'm
not gonna say it was a home run
necessarily but it captured it captured
what I did at that night and at that
particular moment and it was me
basically doing my late-night spot at
The Comedy Store I had been doing that
spot already for like three or four
three years at the time and I said well
you know what I put so much so much of
my time into this spot why not you know
capture it so I always wanted to do this
late-night special like going up in that
last spot after the rooms been beaten
down and what time is this about I well
normally after midnight so I tried for
might the special we did two shows they
we did it in the main room and I guess
they did the first show we did around
like around 10 o'clock and I and I went
on probably around 11 ish and the room
was too crowded actually and I did well
I got laughs I did I'm not gonna say
yeah maybe I did crush but it was a
regular looking kind of thing the second
show we started after 11:00 and there
was you know maybe 150 people then it
because we had good comedians Bilborough
was on it and I think I feel Vaughan was
on it so it was a good show but by the
time I was gonna go on there is still a
lot of people and so I said let's we got
to put on another comedian let's put on
so we had Don Barris come in and Don
goofed around and made things you did
put his Don Barris touch on it so then I
came out and there was like I don't know
35 people in there spread out and I did
my late night comedy said I'm doing a
special I was that was my angle now
here's the deal it was a year and a half
ago essentially and I think I become you
know I'm definitely a better comedian
now but that night what we did I've seen
it I haven't watched it probably for
eight nine months I'm happy with it I'm
not saying it's a it's gonna change the
world but I build it up like it's my big
special it is kind of my big special and
people probably expect to have a full
audience and everything and the in the
crowd is there you know bussed in
audience paid audience so it was a real
audience who didn't know me that people
walking out I go how dare you walk out
this is my special you don't do that and
that a couple of the comedian's
I left the mics open if they wanted to
interact with me and so that I was just
basically making it kind of like what I
was doing
late at night and I think we captured
that so I feel good about it I'm curious
to see how the reaction is gonna be but
this is something I feel like I could
promote meaning like I promoted my TV
show but you know it was kind of weird
promoting me going off the rails
promoting me acting out on Twitter and
being detained at Starbucks promoting me
talking about psychology which was it
was this interesting but the comedy with
this I feel good about it I feel like I
got a bunch of my jokes in it was a lot
of yelling a lot of excitement but
that's what I was doing I was taping my
special
he warned me at the beginning of the
podcast that this was gonna happen I'm
gonna be like 18 towards lots of
forwarding we're doing the farting no
there's a lot of dairy
well it's available it will be available
on Amazon and yeah maybe it will lead to
me doing you know more late night
midnight shows I don't know but I think
it's kind of I'd say I also there's a
couple cool little things in there I
think people will like they'll be
pleasantly surprised at a couple nice
moments and also I'm promoting the
Comedy Store I'm actually talking about
how the Comedy Store is the place to be
and how but it's it's tongue-in-cheek
some of that stuff and silly music and
some backstage like me putting it on
makeup and stretching so I got all that
stuff in and I'm curious to see where it
goes and I'm already thinking about what
my next specialist I feel like you just
got to keep cranking them out and not to
say that there's gonna be another one
but I'd like to think well okay I got
this now I can work for my next one and
I really need to think of myself as a
comedian and I've made that concerted
effort probably for the last three years
or so to like let people know I do
stand-up so like when I put out a tweet
promoting a show I put that microphone
because people knew me as oh you're an
audience warm-up guy oh you are maybe
you're a guy in Chelsea or whatever I
don't know but I put in my mind I have
to think like hey I'm a stand-up I
perform at The Comedy Store I'm doing it
so and I think people do look at me as
you are you have made it
people do Joey's gotta see enters they I
think you're doing a fart ready - I'm
getting a fart ready I leave but it's
been a it's been a long [ __ ] weeks
you understand but I you know I think I
I do get a little I get tension
sometimes I think like with some of the
guys at the Comedy Store I think because
I know him too well I think like I butt
heads sometimes with the guys
and sometimes it's on a podcast or it's
on a video and I feel that that gets to
me a little bit i don't i don't like
having things like that happen but also
i feel like coming I have good
relationships with the comedians you
know people don't always know like like
the eyeball check you got to be there
you have people like have opinions based
off a podcast people have opinions based
off a video they saw of you but they
don't know the relationship between two
people two comedians so sometimes that
stuff gets to me but I know and I think
the comedians know that I've been on the
ground floor a lot of stuff and I
definitely don't feel hate from
comedians but sometimes fans and maybe
this is Twitter or maybe this could be
me jumping in comments which I don't do
like I pick up on some of that so but I
butt heads at times but that's also me
being in those situations doing those
late-night crazy spots you know that
it's like doing warm up it's like last
to be hired first to be fired I'm like
almost too nice sometimes I'm I'm being
nice and I'm not saying people take
advantage of me but I just think I
remember growing up here in the valley I
get sometimes I would get picked on for
being a nice guy
people what was on your business card
what's on your business boy I'm a nice
guy or that leads to be my friend with
the wets the other slogan you know I'm a
model and Pakistan yeah you said some
funny business cards oh brother let me
explain some tea one thing about you is
you don't owe me anything
you put your time and I was there with
you in that basement with roaches 195
that's basically what that [ __ ] on
the ground was a basement with [ __ ]
roaches oh yeah
and big-ass roaches you know but once
you saw the roaches it didn't really
matter because it was home we were so
lucky to be at the [ __ ] on the ground
Mondays and Tuesday nights would call
tormenting Rita Ho Oh Rita al Fox how
Fox tour that's why we both went to war
without
yeah all around I think he does
motivational speaking up those last I
heard yes multiple that's the come up
way how Fox Seattle I had that video I
remember you and Al going at it in the
book you poor al yeah we learned you
know but I think Seattle Jesus that was
like a zillion zillion Brit what a
[ __ ] time yeah I think Seattle we are
right there this is like before Amazon
this is right be I mean Amazon started
in Seattle and we were there they Amazon
started in Pioneer Square did they do
like this yeah I find his Lincoln didn't
let City you know we were there at a
pretty happen in time like the Foo
Fighters were just getting started
Soundgarden Nirvana was you know
happening we were there at a hot moment
not a hot moment but Seattle was kind of
like on the tail end a grunge
the comedy boom was dying out somewhat
but Seattle was just I think a great
spot to be pre-social media pre crazy
internet it was like the last bastion of
the use of art there he is he's right
this the wonders don't quit as those he
spoke that he's number three number
three the pictures look at this beauty
right now the other way the other way
right there okay look at this beauty
there he is how far that's him Joey you
don't talk to me that way have been
doing comedy now for five you Brody
you're not funny to me al please Brody
get away from me al
I enjoy motorcycles a brain that faded
on that one pretty good though right
good acting he was he used to get pissed
off it won't you do to him you know he
had like a handicapped issue something
that happened to him get a brain injury
thing a motorcycle accident see if you
can Wikipedia oh my god well thank you
al Fox isn't Wikipedia al Fox motorcycle
read this no no motorcycle went just
alpha
okay I gotta break his balls it's a
because I gotta say well I would think
there's a story behind it well if it's a
wiki then we'll read it but I'm not wait
for my little boy I didn't mean to do
that
you already got hit by a bus the poor
bastard I don't think he's listening to
this podcast he has to be what she's
gotta be the Facebook she's gonna go but
it was different doing open mics in
Seattle it was like you would get real
audience you would get that Fox was
don't quit association right there
Alf Fox is a founder and president
they're not-for-profit winners don't
quit award-winning comment send them an
email really me to inspire and enable
all people young and old those are
disabilities and those without to accept
the life they've been given where's the
number I don't think the eyes right now
right that don't matter leave a message
brother them up when they're gonna give
of that I was on the screen for a second
yeah it's alright but then contact now
Fox send them a message Lee son this is
Bradley Stevenson he wants to do it to a
woman
no motivational speaker or as comedian I
can be doing motivational whatever you
want to do both he isn't killing the
road you take him out for a week with
tape but we'll sell that to anybody I've
got a sidecar motorcycle sidecar he
could motivate for you so a four to five
does rush Oh watch it off the screen and
call a mother put her on speakerphone
what if he answers just hang up local
Americans do not making the call back
he's embracing change
[Laughter]
hey al it's a longtime friend here Brody
Stevens what do you think we're having a
great conversation
my pal Joey Diaz how Fox you bad
[ __ ] you we're just talking
about Seattle your name came up a lot of
good times Joey and I were still we're
down here in LA having a we're having a
blast we're still blue hope you're still
going it looks like you are positive
motivational speaking
what is don't quit [ __ ] winners
don't quit get a complimentary three
chapter sample of Al's newest book Al's
got a book coming out Jesus Joseph and
Mary's out Cindy it's the [ __ ] book
we ain't cut this [ __ ] al Fox winners
don't quit Association and bracing
change inspiring people to believe in
their own possibilities he knows what it
is he wrote it oh he wrote it Laemmle
only my business end of the a Street
exit mint al we love you we love you I
was thinking about you
that was fun thanks for letting us call
you okay stick like escape stay stay
black got a call back and get that oh
you wanna hear that again yeah that was
classic okay Alphonse you can't write
that [ __ ] that was funny that was fun
you can't write that's just to let you
know people well not wait I hit bull's
genius or bring any bad entertainment
Bernie when you talk to me that way al
please
at least we're telling you the truth
here so we weren't lying that's the most
important point that [ __ ] beauty oh
that was funny
daddy had read oh who sold pills on the
first of every month she had like big
shipments of valium from all those pills
that you know Bob's annex enough went
that way she was getting hard [ __ ] she
was a he she was a he before it was cool
yeah that sent him an email
we tellin we were talking with Milan we
love him we want to put him on the
[ __ ] window quit association tour
but you're missing her anymore right now
right now doc tomorrow morning okay yeah
right now set up an email please sent
tell him listen we want to put you on
the withers don't quit tour contact Lisa
at the coordinated but there was
something about doing you know doing let
me give you his cell phone no we I like
that he's gonna call us back in 24 8
million people on the [ __ ] line
nobody gives you their cell phone I want
wheezes poor bastard he gives yourself
and right now we call the [ __ ] money
right at the balls they're like wow he's
a good [ __ ] do it
nope that's how giggles there ain't no
[ __ ] giggles gary taylor terry taylor
that was doing it before Terry Taylor
with the Vietnam vet what's the guy's
name
drunk or was his name he hated me but I
used together old work I'm gonna put
your name down
what do you like tinker with everybody's
act like said he knew Seinfeld that was
this thing like Seinfeld wasn't to do
that tell you the work clean this [ __ ]
so I would work dirty and then when he
would pull up his Maserati Oh whenever
the [ __ ] he had well he would come into
the showroom and work clean and he just
walked through the back for about 48
seconds and he'd go into the kitchen and
he goes right back to your act oh really
yeah
so he was only in there for 40 seconds
tops he would stop for one beat to
listen to your punchline make sure there
was no [ __ ] of nothing dirty you could
see him walking through but as soon as
he walked in the kitchen man I finished
up with the headliner up
I drank at the tab there so you enjoyed
your shows there yes I did
you know at that time man listen there
was 1996-97
yep I was happy to fart in a [ __ ]
glass do you understand me I think you
did that tonight I've been in prison
I've been in a [ __ ] war with my
ex-wife and now guess what I wasn't
living in Ojai rising I wasn't paying
the [ __ ] thousand dollars a month
mortgage mm-hmm but I was keeping the
lights on it yep
paying for groceries yep and paying my
side of the rent with ya sometimes it
took a big wallet Oh
sometimes it took 50 hits of something
you know sometimes it took whatever but
every month I was starting to make
payments with commie money
mm-hmm and that was the best feeling in
the world and if I show you those
notebooks today if I bring the notebooks
to you from 95 to 2004 you could see the
yet like I wish today I could take those
notebooks and put them into a computer
so they could put a graph together and
do something for comics like a seminar
to show them the slow escalation of the
money and for ten years there was no
money there was nobody but it went from
8,000 to 9600 to 11 for in 12 8 hmm a
hundred thousand one year whoa whoa whoa
then back to 14 the next yeah yeah or
more about a hundred thousand one year
than 14-thousand next oh yeah all I did
was triple runs and headlining gigs
that's eight hundred a week when I was
making 14 thousand a year of Academy
that means I'm not [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] I'm making more money than if I
was poor poor poor and I'm not enough to
live on any restrictions once I started
making 14 grand a year 16 grand a year
20 grand a year alright you're okay as a
comedian you're like okay I can pay this
I can make this happen
you can make this happen because you're
getting money you get 1200 a week a
thousand a week you're gonna beat the
road for everything that's worth if you
could stay on the couch you're gonna
stay on the couch if you could stay on
the floor you're gonna stay on the floor
if you could [ __ ] what's that should
have being being an Airbnb but you're
gonna commit to it
and that's when you really make that
little extra money on the road you know
there's so much money in comedy in the
beginning but there's not but if you
believe in yourself in today's comedy
world mm-hmm with t-shirts CDs and pens
and just a variable for everything and
the content that you could pull out at a
time you know
everybody's from everybody wants to be
on Netflix but you could still become a
star on YouTube why doesn't anybody know
that because everybody thinks that
you're gonna put a video on YouTube but
if it doesn't everybody who puts a video
up expects the video to go viral like
they're not gonna do any work they just
want the video to go viral Frank put up
as many videos as they can but they
don't understand that for a video to go
viral don't get me wrong
a nobody can put a video up and rock it
up and down with a cat and get a million
downloads because it's cute I'm talking
about the guy that promotes his social
media six months before he releases his
stand-up seven minutes I'm gonna get out
there and start doing it that's a big
difference
that's a big difference people will give
you a three-minute clip to let you know
that thirty are coming out on YouTube
that's a big difference you just gave me
something so now I'm committed to you
know he's gonna live tweet when you do
the YouTube thing you know let me tell
you something I couldn't get a special
on Netflix today I'd shoot three
ten-minute sets of the Icehouse and cut
them down to seven Fulham on you yeah
take those numbers go to youtube and get
them to give me money for the next place
because YouTube is about to start buying
content they just hit big with the
Karate Kid 25 million viewers the first
[ __ ] day or the first three days
they're gonna come in they're all over
the world they're in position they're
like communists they're all over the
world they're in position all I need to
do is just raise a rifleman no gawa but
I feel like it's a popularity thing I
see I see YouTube numbers and I feel
like comedy it is subjective I'm not
comparable
your reason to [ __ ] you gotta give me
a reason to watch you okay like anything
else
friends Everybody Loves Raymond well
whatever's if your comedy is different
like I feel like my comedy it takes a
little while for people to get that's
fine you do something very unique always
remember that you're not doing with Joey
Diaz and what [ __ ] Harvey's dude it
was Duncan doing with Joe Rogan's don't
build birds don't you're doing something
that what's the toughest thing you ever
drank Lee what's the toughest booze that
you said to you something then what that
was okay but I don't know in Lee's world
I guess probably tequila I mean I like
tequila get to drop maybe vodka throw
these people's tequila just like me once
they understand where Brody's coming
from they fall in love with Brody
well I want Brody doing what he's doing
I'm kind of jealous of bro he in a lot
of way because that was my world I had
found a way to make you love me after
about 20 months of dying on the 12:30
slot box
it took me honest to god let's just just
say let's just say for breakeven took me
16 months I may be lying to both he is
nobody listening but it took me that
long to figure out how to destroy at
that spot but once I figured out how to
destroy the 12:30 12:45 spot it became a
different game for me yeah it's a
different game and when I watch you I
watched you about eight months ago I was
down there late one night I watched the
first three minutes you bring them into
your world it's that guy at 12:30 who
has that funky [ __ ] show on TBS but
you can't watch [ __ ] those three two
[ __ ] guys to that you know I'm no
rule for camel Kimmel's got that [ __ ]
horrible [ __ ] check I don't
understand what she's saying half the
time
[ __ ] Jimmy Fallon's dancing up and
down with Obama's wife I don't mind with
that
gasps I just don't want to what dancing
I feel like laughing and the other guys
got some political guy on that talking
about taxes I'm in the move for that let
me put that crazy guy on that's up there
with a [ __ ] thing yelling at the
audience and they fall in love with you
Brody that's a different gift I saw it
that but I saw it like I'm [ __ ] eight
months ago like I told you I was driving
home on my brother he's come a long
[ __ ] way and then I saw it before you
shot the special I'm sorry
and then when they told me you had shot
the special and you were shooting it and
see so I picked it up I was really happy
I was like this is gonna hit this might
become wicked
like right now you have nothing to lose
if in the next year nobody picks you up
come over here
let's talk because there's a way for you
to do a [ __ ] show at midnight by
yourself in your kitchen kitchen eating
blending protein swinging kettlebells
gone over baseball scores try this at
our show if you want you can have a
gasps did not we don't need a guest
showing you cat your dog pictures of you
use yeah I've got although talking to
your mother on the phone I do that today
on my podcast bro I don't even need to
know I know what you know it's money for
you I know because I don't want today on
the podcast I know you twenty years I
mean right why are you talking to the
[ __ ] periscope the phone records you
know yeah what do you know what the [ __ ]
you think I'm doing mom I'm doing a
podcast I told you that 20 times oh oh I
thought you met the koi at 12:20 no
because you're actually going to tell
the koi at 12:20 why call her for the
podcast right tell her to call you
either which you call which is are you
insulting I should go now you told me
12:20 mom please I'm doing about why
would I tell you to call me at 12:20
embarrassing mom didn't tell you to call
me yes you did
that's what you want that confusion yeah
I can do that yeah yeah 12 enter all the
talent [ __ ] and then Hitler it's like
that Don Rickles story when he went over
to the table and he saw Sinatra he will
know what this allows me to do me a
favor
time with this girl oh come on we say
hello after you finish that Sinatra goes
up it says hey man how you doing and Don
Rickles Frank what the [ __ ] can't you
see I mean yeah everywhere I've know
that Joe that's father that's Cory
that's it man you know you have a good
product it's just getting out there and
that's what nobody understands you're
not gonna put your [ __ ] on YouTube a
million people gonna watch and I wish it
was that easy I wish it was that easy
you have to give them a reason you have
to give them a reason on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram and for them to
go home
well the chick pops up and goes hey
click this link I'm gonna show you my
[ __ ] okay how can you do that when I
was showing somebody your [ __ ] your
[ __ ] is your video of you doing eight
minutes at the store at midnight yeah
how that's the same American ingenuity
that you have to figure it out and how
many times a BOTY is clicked onto a
chick that's willing your annika way you
both have at one time or another you
didn't know some hot asian chick as I
click on my link look at my [ __ ] and
next thing you know you're in [ __ ]
China at a Knitting Factory budget
Chinese world singing communism songs
and [ __ ] we both done it how did she get
you to open that up she got more we lyin
secondly I saw the wrestler with Mickey
Rourke I knew about the wrestler nine
months in advance the producers did
something to make me know that this
movie was coming out nine months they
planted the seed it's the same thing
with CDs or anything gonna do a June
18th I'm coming out with something I
plan to the see mm-hmm I want people to
go in there what's gonna make them go in
there count and circle the 18th
what would make you circle a date the
dentist the doctor or some chick sucking
your dick are you having a gig for money
how can I get you to circle that number
for a comedy show or Stu 20-second
Amazon yeah you Capri Mona it's the same
concept later I always look at it that
way how can I get from you what I want
it's the same thing only without all the
[ __ ] they just make it so much
[ __ ]
either think it's a special pain it's
not [ __ ] special we can all do it
chicks do tell us all the time how do
you remember to pick up a ticket 7:30 on
a [ __ ] Monday night you've got a lot
on your mind he remembered to pick her
up at 7:30 because she had a sucky dick
oh I missed that yes you're gonna circle
the calendar all circle a calendar [ __ ]
yeah I'll do a circle all sir circle
jerk that calendar I know you will so
June 22nd
what is it coming on it's gonna be on
Amazon June 22nd Brody Stephens live
from the main room
and I'm happy with it I haven't watched
it to be honest with you like I said for
like probably nine months so I'm curious
to see I think it will hold up hopefully
and it's it's happening whether I like
it or not and I do like it so I think I
can do I've got to start promoting it a
little more this helps I want to say
thank you for that please do me a favor
you know this guy's family preview all
the [ __ ] thing what's gonna cost you
two dollars pre Ottoman support Brody
Stevens East Church family he's my
family for 20 years you guys know I love
him I called him up last week just to
figure out what was going on hand and
seen him at the store and one thing led
to another I wanted to come back on the
podcast I know he lives close by and I
mean there's late spots mm-hmm [ __ ] it
it's nice and cool mm-hmm why do a
podcast at the daytime this way you're a
so we could do another night at the cool
[ __ ] Valley
I like this yeah the breeze coming in
through the Cahuenga Pass it's great to
see you it's great to see the damage
you've done even going back for the best
in a sports show when I would sit there
rich Williams yeah I'm listening to you
[ __ ] just make me howl with those
kids you would make me [ __ ] hell I
would target Rogan Rogan you gotta see
what he's doing over there and just that
whole thing that whole experience I
think I still have that tape I'm being
the best damn sports show Tom Arnold
roasts yeah do you remember we roasted
Yahoo have that tape somewhere that was
way before long this yard that I told
Michael Irvin on that tape that we're
gonna work together pretty soon you guys
did and we had
we're gonna think of that wonder when
that [ __ ] tape is now people would
dive this a crook croc bill Bill Maher
bill ma um the Gert led uh lady one not
Moishe mo mo nique she won the mone she
won an Academy Award would you know who
else was on that girl who left awesome
with the ABC Monday Night Football Lisa
Guerrero yeah where is she she's like on
Inside Edition would you still be
[ __ ] legs yeah we've had uh
I mean so many people through the best
damn sports show and I think people are
more nostalgic looking back at it gets a
lot of love and you know we were there
you were there crushing it live these
weren't taped pieces these are live to
tape but you were doing it live right
there in the middle of the show and that
was always impressive to see I mean I
was right there on the floor why do you
think it was an education I mean they'd
be over you know on there in one side of
the studio maybe doing the new thing and
you'd be all the way over on the other
side like behind a you know in front of
a green screen just knocking it out
doing your stuff or always you know
really uh a pro there so I saw that you
and Loni love was on quite a bit so you
guys were great and the guests were
awesome and we were really on you know
ground floor of sports and comedy all
those guys are still working Chris Rose
is on you know and they'll be networking
everything John Sally's got cannabis
clubs everywhere his vegan John Kruk is
doing Phillies broadcast Michael Irvin
we had Michael Strahan Steve Harvey Jeff
Dunham I brought that guy back you know
he was down nobody was into him and then
George Greenberg the producer loved this
Jeff Dunham puppet guy and I would push
those puppets push it push up and next
thing you know this guy's because Jeff
Dunham was successful at one point then
he went down low and then he came back
and I feel like best damn sports show we
got them back we we get those guys
coming by to like rehabilitate their
careers like Daniel
Baldwin and you know Michael Irvin even
had a lot of problems they put him on
there and you know we had Steven a Smith
getting started Jalen Rose so many
people that that are still where all the
guys with MLB on Fox with a-rod and all
those guys doing the World Series
they're all from best damn sports show
and they went to the NFL Network so you
that you know I feel good about that I
feel you know sense of pride that I
brought the energy you brought it the
guys on the show and that's why I
learned a lot of you know how important
energy was because it would affect the
show do you get these kids these
inner-city football kids slouchin and I
go guys we got a sit up let's go I play
baseball Reseda you know you gotta like
talk back to them a little bit and the
kids would respond and the coaches loved
it like you can really dig into these
kids and I go you play football right
you see Michael Irvin right there he's
got three Super Bowl rings you want to
meet them well let's start picking it up
a notch let's go energy matters and like
that would pump up the show same thing
like that when I did warm-up for Joe
Rogan at the man show you were on that
and the same thing you know Doug
Stanhope it's like pumping up the
audience going for it and like believing
and being I was really into the show so
but I saw especially at best damn sports
show how energy mattered how caring
mattered because I just saw the results
it was a Thad this show went on for a
thousand shows and then I went to
Chelsea and I did 400 there and I saw
the results and I just try to show
people that there is something to it
there is something there you can tap
into it and I think like it's been
harder it's harder to like get crowds to
go with you on things like that you
can't yell at crowds anymore you can't
get on them they'll turn on you you know
before you let you would say like guys
I'm busting my I'm busting my ass up
here you got to help me out I'm not
making that much money I park in the
same lot with you guys let's go
like now that they would like fight back
on you like that you're a teacher you're
a cop you're an authority figure so the
last few years I've been like budding
head
that's why I've gotten how to warm up
somewhat because it was just friction
whereas I was at best damn could really
like not yell at the kids but you can
shake on you young you and you would say
[ __ ] them from time to time you know you
sitting here talking about best damn and
the show at Joe and Stanhope just it
just strengthens what I was talking
about that I saw you on this journey and
you saw me on the same [ __ ] journey
everyone what's every week on their
thing here we are 20 years later and
[ __ ] North Hollywood in the [ __ ]
Valley yeah your home and I want to wish
you the best of luck
tweet it on June 21st and will retweet
this I'll tweet it out mind the church
family what's going on on Instagram will
have about one by one podcast and I
wanna thank you man and I wanna thank
you for being like growing up to being a
[ __ ] gentleman and I'm believing in
your thing cuz you're still here you
could've quit a long time ago and went
back to see I got a girlfriend gave me
guitar lessons on Alki Beach for the
single 20 years so thank you very much
I want to thank lease I happen before I
go real quick like I told you in the
[ __ ] beginning of the show for you
jeez there's only one place that's Fuji
sports.com why because they got the all
torn the all purpose like D they got the
super rod oh they got the new cycle the
cycle 2.0 there's a cow and they have
the one with the e that I love to death
I love my blue yeah I forget what the
[ __ ] it's called liver Baja no evolution
or uh elemental elemental I love my
[ __ ] elemental they were all like
geez you can hang on them King Kong can
[ __ ] hang on nothing will happen
you understand me so go to Fuji Sports
calm right now press in church bad and
get 10% off kneepads knees mouth
whatever you're gonna get the MMA get an
impressive church number one so we get
the credit let these [ __ ] know
we're now [ __ ] around help out the
church and help out help us out a little
bit number two listen to me hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go while hiring is nice simple fast
and small
hiring used to be hard multiple job site
stacks of resumes and a confusing review
process
but today hiring can be easy and you
could have and you only have to go to
one place to get it done that zip
recruiter dot-com / Joey listen zip
recruiter is the best they send your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there
with that powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply for your jobs
as application comes in zip recruiter
analyzes each one in spots lights the
top candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruit is so effective that 80% of
the employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate through the site
within one day that is right within one
day with results like that it's no
wonder
zip recruited is the highest rating
hiring site in America today right now
what I'm gonna do is this the church
family can try zip recruiter for free
gratis free at zip recruited comm slash
church for free give it a shot what do
you got to lose that zip recruiter comm
slash Church Church CH you are CH zip
recruiter comm slash Church stop banging
your head off the wall the guy you're
looking for or the woman you're looking
for is right in front zip recruiter the
smartest way to hide I want to thank
Fuji Sports calm and I want to thank zip
recruiter for having our back and I want
to thank you guys for being savages
don't forget we're back Monday next week
and Wednesday don't worry about nothing
I'm going to Disneyland [ __ ] listen I
want to thank my man
Brody Brody Stevie and enjoying I want
to thank my little brother the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I see you [ __ ]
next week have a great weekend stay
black write your goals and do your 22
push-ups kick this [ __ ] melee